not every '90s sci-fi movie can be as
popular as The Fifth Element or
Terminator 2 from an apocalyptic take on
a classic myth to multiple flicks about
killer video games these little known
gems from the end of the Millennium
still shouldn't be missed all these
years later Jean Claude vanam fans know
all about 1989 cyborg it's a film with
an odd history it basically exists
because the Canon group couldn't make
Masters of the Universe too or
Spider-Man so director Albert P
assembled a new plan with all the and
sets despite being cobbled together with
spare parts the Sci-Fi Action story
received a sequel in 1993 titled cyborg
2 glass Shadow but vanam was nowhere to
be found despite not having the muscles
from Brussels flexing and doing the
splits cyborg 2 still managed to get
Angelina jool Lee Elias cus Billy Drago
and Jack Palance signed on directed by
Michael Schroeder it tells the story of
cyborg assassin cash ree who fights back
against her creators when she learns
that she's meant to be taken out of
commission naturally she makes a friend
and falls in love during her
action-packed Adventure while cyborg 2
is far from a masterpiece it's still
great fun for when you just want to sit
down and turn your brain off Jolie might
not be the biggest fan of her debut as a
leading actor but her performance does
show hints of what would end up making
her one of the brightest stars in
Hollywood aside from that it's a
perfectly cheesy actioner with some
outstanding
onliners if you want to dine with the
Devil
you'll need a long
spoon how can a film that made over $45
million worldwide up a12 million budget
be considered obscure that's a good
question but mention 1992's Fortress to
anybody nowadays and most people won't
have a clue what you're talking about
directed by steuart Gordon and starring
Christopher Lambert and Kurt wood Smith
Fortress takes place in a future in
which families are only allowed one
child per household when John Henry
brenick and his wife Karen attend
attempt to have a second child in secret
they are caught and chucked into a
Maximum Security Prison where cruelty is
the order of the day naturally the only
option is escape believing The Fortress
is a nearly impossible task the New York
Times Steven Holden summed up the film
perfectly saying it Blends RoboCop the
handmaid's taale and Brave New World
into something scary original and grimly
amusing while the prison escape plot
isn't terribly unique Fortress keeps the
action in excitement moving at a
Breakneck speed
the film received a sequel in 2000
titled Fortress 2 re-entry which saw
Lambert reprise his role for manga fans
bansan and tetsu oara Fist of the North
Star is widely regarded as one of the
most important series of all time it was
an entry point into the medium for many
fans and it still stands Supreme to this
day as you might expect there have been
several adaptations of the story and the
1995 liveaction film starring Gary
Daniels Chris Penn costus Mandalore and
Malcolm McDow is certainly one of them
directed by Tony Randall this movie
takes the story back to the beginning
Daniels plays martial arts Warrior Ken
Shiro as he seeks revenge against his
arch rival Lord Shin in the barren
Wasteland of a post World War III Earth
while the liveaction adaption doesn't
hold a candle to the 1986 animated film
it has its own unique charm in the same
way that something like 1994 Street
Fighter makes for an entertaining watch
it's cheesier than a block of mozzarella
and the effects are laughably bad by
today's standards but the fight scenes
make it worthwhile for a Friday night
viewing reviewer Owen at the action
Elite agreed writing this is quite a
surreal film but also one of Daniel's
more ambitious you can't tell it had a
limited budget but the fight scenes
alone make this worth watching with
Daniels doing what he does best don't
turn your back on me you're already
dead some science fiction movies are
rather serious Affairs filled with
solemn reminders that Earth is a tiny
Speck in the vastness of space and that
our time on our planet is limited space
truckers is not one of those movies
Stuart Gordon's 1996 feature is a
light-hearted romp starring Dennis
Hopper as a working man John Canyon
who's just trying to get his next
paycheck by transporting some cargo to
Earth no questions asked what he doesn't
know is that his latest shipment
contains some Killer Robots and that
he's about to encounter some Sinister
space pirates starring alongside Hopper
are Steven dorf Debbie Mazar Charles Dan
and Barbara krampton space truckers
never ends up becoming a complete parody
of the genre like Space Balls but it
certainly doesn't take itself too
seriously either gone with the twins
Mike Massie gave the film a positive
rating riding Space truckers adopts a
fun and action-packed yet oddly violent
and bizarre tone mixing light
grotesqueries with plenty of Star Wars
derivations if you've seen enough Star
Wars and think that Star Trek is a
little to White Collar space truckers
might just be the movie for you 2 and 1
half decades before Blue Beetle landed
in movie theaters another sci-fi story
about an alien AI cyber suit was
released albeit one made for a younger
audience and with a much lower budget
writer and director Manny Cotto star kid
follows school kid Spencer Griffith
whose whole life changes after he puts
on a mysterious costume from outer space
in a local junkyard it's not long before
he starts getting into all sorts of
mishaps but he's forced to shape up
quick ly once an evil alien shows up in
search of the device why does everyone
want to beat me up in the end Spencer
learns that he doesn't actually need the
suit to be a hero after all the real
power lies within celebrated critic
Roger Ebert gave star kid a glowing
review writing it has a sweet heart and
a lot of Sly wit and the symbiosis
between boy and Cyborg is handled
cleverly for kids of a certain age it
pushes the right buttons it may not be
the best choice if you're looking for
something gritty and violent but star
kid is a fun family film that's suitable
for viewers of all ages up until his
Unforgettable vocal performance as the
Joker in Batman the Animated Series Mark
Hamill struggled to be perceived as
anyone other than Luke Skywalker so in
1991 he took a shot at the liveaction
adaptation of yoshiki takaya's manga
series The gerver directed by screaming
mad George and Steve wank the Sci-Fi
superhero flick Stars Jack Armstrong as
Shawn Barker a man who discovered an
alien armor that bonds with him and
turns him into a superpowered cyborg
Hamill appears in the film as the
supporting character CIA agent Max Reed
but he received top billing because of
his star power even though the Guyver
never received the Fanfare of Robocop or
the Terminator the movie earned love
from the manga Community along with
reviewers who appreciated what it
achieved with a tiny budget of $3
million Ed Travis of synapse wrote onep
part Power Rangers all parts awesome the
guy is weird wild and wonderful
featuring incredible creature designs
and makeup effects fantastic martial
arts action and an impossibly weird and
indelible World on all what must have
been a shoestring budget the film
received a 1994 sequel titled Guyver
dark hero but neither Hamill nor
Armstrong returned for the movie
nowadays some of the most popular video
games around are free to play but back
in the '90s a free game was a much more
enticing offer that's how the characters
of Albert Pan's arcade find themselves
sucked into a virtual world created and
ruled by a nefarious bad guy of the same
name after Alex Manning and her friends
are given a new virtual reality game by
a stranger to test out and play things
take a dark turn as they find themselves
in a never-ending death trap that's more
like Dark Souls than Mario Party arcade
comes across as something of a Tron
ripoff and there was actually a legal
situation because of the CGI
similarities regardless though it
manages to capture the culture of the
era in both its looks look and feel with
a script by David esger who would go on
to pen Blockbuster films like The Dark
Knight and blade Pion maintains a
delicate balance between the movie
sci-fi and horror elements if you're in
the mood for Pure B movie Vibes and
plenty of '90s fashion you really can't
go wrong with
arcade I am the future I am
arcade the epic poem Beowolf is a staple
of historical literature and it's been
adapted into multiple movies of the same
name the most famous of these is the
2007 CGI Beowolf film which was directed
by Robert zamis from a screenplay
written by Neil Gaiman and Roger Avery
but 8 years earlier there was another
directed by grahe Baker 1999's bolf
Embraces both sci-fi and fantasy
elements as it takes the story into a
post-apocalyptic World in this version
Christopher Lambert plays Beowolf as he
fights the Beast known as the grindle
while also harboring plenty of his own
secrets Lambert is joined by the likes
of Rona Mitra as Kyra and Oliver cotton
as rockar the 1999 adaption may not have
the Pomp and Circumstance of the 2007
retelling nor does it bother with the
intricacies of the classic story but as
a sci-fi fantasy movie it makes for a
fun viewing experience the set design is
impressive the action never falters and
lamber provides a committed performance
with his modern take on one of the
oldest characters around before gamer
and Chooser die brain scan paved the way
for video game themed sci-fi horror in
1994 directed by John Flynn from a
script written by Andrew Kevin Walker
the film stars Edward Furlong as a
teenager named Michael who becomes
obsessed with being a virtual murderer
in the realistic video game brain scan
by the time he realizes that the crimes
he's carrying out in game are happening
in real life it's too late to stop an
evil entity from the game known as
trickster suddenly appears and he won't
allow Michael to put down down the
controller and stop playing the devilish
game brain scan wasn't exactly warmly
received upon arrival with a Critic
score of 133% on Rotten Tomatoes it's
clear that professional reviewers
weren't into it the audience score of
60% on the other hand is proof that
brain scan is just silly enough to work
for most people doesn't have to make
sense all these horror movies you watch
does death death Death make sense in an
interview with FCO over a decade later f
revealed that the role of the trickster
as portrayed by T Ryder Smith was his
favorite in the film and that he didn't
have a great experience working with
furong as he put it the trickster was
the core of the movie and What attracted
me to the script we found this stage
actor to play the trickster and he was
extraordinary Eddie Furlong was a
15-year-old kid who couldn't act you had
to slap him awake every morning I don't
want to get into knocking people but I
was not a big Eddie Furlong fan David
Bradley remains an unheralded hero of of
early 9s action Cinema while the typical
b-grade Canon film Fair had slowly
started to evaporate into The Ether
Bradley kept the schlocky genre Alive by
starring in films that had the budget of
a cheeseburger he may be better known
for turning up in the later American
Ninja sequels but Bradley helped
Kickstart another franchise in 1993
cyborg cop helmed by American Ninja
director Sam firstenberg cyborg cop sees
DEA agent Jack Ryan no not that Jack
Ryan rece reive a distress call from his
brother Phillip who finds himself under
threat on a Caribbean Island Jack heads
off to find his brother but he's too
late after he arrives he discovers that
philli is now a dangerous cyborg that
needs to be stopped cyborg cop is about
as subtle about its influences as a
sledgehammer to the head but it deserves
a place alongside other lowbudget Sci-Fi
Action films of the era forget about the
plot seeing a martial artist take on a
cyborg is more than enough reason to
give this one a shot if cyborg cop is up
your alley be sure to check out the two
sequels that were released in 1994 and
[Music]